>>Joel Webber: Good afternoon.
My name is Joel Webber on the Google Web Toolkit
team.
>>Adam Schuck: And hi. I'm Adam Schuck from
Sydney, Australia.
I work on Google Wave.
>>Joel Webber: We're going to talk a little
bit today about performance in GWT and as
it applies to the learning's of the Google
Wave team.
Also, don't forget, there is a live Wave going
on at the following bit.ly link if you're
not already there.
There's been a little turbulence there, but
it should be sorted out now.
>>Adam Schuck: Okay. So you're all sitting
in the audience today, and you're obviously
interested in performance, but it's important
to know, why does it matter?
Why architect for performance?
Well, it turns out, speed of your application
really matters.
Users want a fast application.
And we've certainly seen this with Google.com.
We've learned the faster it is, the more people
use it.
Typically, we talk in three powers of ten
in terms of time limits that matter when you're
writing a web application; point one of a
second, one second, and ten seconds.
And these are rough guidelines of important
times that you want to keep.
"Point one of a second" is what you want to
do if you want the application to feel instantaneous.
So, if your user is typing, everything should
happen in less than a tenth of a second.
"One second" is what you want if the user's
flow of thought should stay uninterrupted.
So, if I'm clicking some buttons and anything
takes longer than one second, I might get
a little bit distracted.
One second's important there.
And "ten seconds" is what you really want
to do if you want to keep the user's attention
focused.
So, if anything in your application takes
longer than ten seconds, "I've already Alt-tabbed;
I'm checking Face book; watching videos on
YouTube; change. Oh, it's finally loaded.
What was I doing again?" Ten seconds is a
really good guideline that, if anything in
your application takes longer than that…what
was I talking about again?
>>Joel Webber: Exactly.
>>Adam Schuck: Exactly.
>>Joel Webber: So, we're going to talk about
this, because I mentioned earlier, from two
perspectives: myself working on GWT, perspective
of the tool builder.
That is, what can we do to make GWT faster,
either through the compiler or through its
libraries, so that your app is faster with
you doing little or no work?
>>Adam Schuck: And I'll be presenting from
the Google Wave perspective.
Google Wave, if you weren't already aware,
is build in GWT.
And we put a lot of work into making our application
faster.
We know we have a long way to go, but we're
a lot faster than we used to be.
And I'll give a demo of that in a second.
But, the reason that the two of us are here
on stage today is because the GWT team and
the Wave teams work very closely together.
We both absolutely believe in the importance
of speed.
And, as a result, whenever we discover something,
we share it with the GWT team and vice versa.
So we're trying to help…together… make
GWT better, so you don't have to worry about
these problems.
And for those of you who haven't actually
seen Google Wave since Google I/O last year,
maybe you haven't dusted off your accounts
you received.
Just a quick reminder, Hands up in the crowd
if you've ever opened a really large wave
in Google Wave.
Okay. Keep your arm up if you found it slow.
Wow, people who didn't even have their hand
up before put their hands up for that.
[laughing]
>>Joel Webber: That's because they never succeeded
in opening the Wave.
>>Adam Schuck: Bingo, okay. I should have
said "attempted."
Okay. You all know the problem.
I am about to do a magic trick, which, for
some of you, you'll be surprised at; I'm going
to try and open.
And, of course, I've made an offering to the
demo gods today.
>>Joel Webber: My fingers are crossed.
>>Adam Schuck: This wave has 370 messages
in it, and I'm going to click -- 3-2-1.
[click] That was less than a second, right?
>>Joel Webber: Within a second. It's close.
>>Adam Schuck: All right. Put your hand back
up if that's not fast enough for you.
Good. We're going to make it faster for all
of you.
It's not fast enough for me.
I forgot to put my hand up as well.
So, we've done a lot of work previously that
would actually grind your browser to a halt.
It would take a long time before you could
even see the content.
So we're going to talk a little bit about
some of the tricks that we've been using to
try and make Wave faster.
>>Joel Webber: So we're going to talk about
this from four perspectives.
There's really four major parts you need to
consider when you're trying to make your app
fast.
First is "start up", right? We're talking
about web apps.
Web apps need to start fast.
That's what we expect of them.
When they don't, that's bad.
And people typically won't stay with an app
that doesn't start fast, especially if they're
new to it.
"Fetching data"… these are web applications.
Therefore, they're distributed in practically
all real instances.
Distributed networks are typically slow.
The Internet is certainly, is often quite
slow.
And you don't want to fetch more data than
you need or too often.
"Rendering", talking about the web browser.
Web browser has pretty unusual performance
characteristics, and you need to get data
on the screen fast.
Then, "user interactions," these are the things
that fall into that 100 millisecond or point
one of a second limit that Adam talked about
earlier that, if you don't fall into that
range, your app feels sluggish.
You may have heard the word "sluggish" a lot
if you were here this morning for Kelly Norton's
talk.
People think sluggish apps feel bad.
They think they're low quality.
They just don't feel right.
And then, Adam's going to talk a little bit
about performance measurement.
That is, once you've got your app as fast
as you want it to be, or at least under some
reasonable threshold, you're released. You
want to keep it fast.
When you make it faster, you want to keep
it faster.
So you want to catch regressions.
>>Adam Schuck: Okay. So we mentioned four
main areas where your application can be faster.
The first of these is "start up."
You want your application to load quickly.
And by "quickly," we mean, much less time
than ten seconds. Oops.
>>Joel Webber: Sorry.
>>Adam Schuck: [chuckle] We're competing.
"Concurrency control presently not as good
as Google Wave." Who would have thought?
Okay, start up.
Where does the time go when you're starting
up your application?
There's four main places. Fetching the script.
So, if I have a really bad dial-up network
connection, it can take a lot of time to download
the JavaScript.
Secondly, "evaluating the script."
So, if I have a slow computer, it might take
awhile for the browser to evaluate this JavaScript
that I've just downloaded.
"Fetching the initial data." So now, "Okay,
we've started up the application.
We've evaluated it.
Now, we need to know what, in Wave's case,
what waves do they have in their inbox?
What are their contacts? What are their folders?
Etc.
And once we've done that, of course, "building
the application structure."
So we need to put all the panels in place,
wire everything up, get a communication channel
running.
All of these four things in your start-up
sequence can add up to quite a slow start-up.
Let's look at what a typical out-of-the-box
GWT start-up sequence looks like.
We're looking at four roundtrips.
Four roundtrips, which, for people who live
in Australia, can actually add up.
There we go. Another Aussie, hurray! [laughing]
It can really add up if you have a high-latency
connection.
Now, the four roundtrips.
First one is, we download the host page.
So this is initial HTML creates the structure.
Secondly, GWT, we download what's called a
"selection script."
This script in the browser figures out what
browser are they using, what language do they
want to talk, etc.
Now, we know exactly what version of your
application we want to download.
So now I know, "Okay. Let's download the French
Safari version of Google Wave."
Once we've done that, then we actually fetch
that version of JavaScript.
We evaluate it.
So, if there's a lot of JavaScript, takes
awhile to evaluate, especially on a slow machine.
Now that we've finally done that, we've got
the communication channel up and running.
Only now can we start fetching the actual
data, so, the inbox, the contacts etc.
And that, of course, requires roundtrip, not
just to your front end, but all the way through
your back end.
This adds up to quite a bit of time.
Turns out, we can do a lot better than this.
We can actually reduce the four roundtrips
down to two roundtrips.
And we can actually do one, but I'll tell
you why that's not actually better.
So, first optimization we make is, instead
of downloading the selection script and, in
the browser, figuring out what version of
your GWT application to run; rather, we base
off the http headers of your first request
which version we should serve.
So, the server, the front end can say, "Aha!
We now know from the user agent they're using
Safari."
And we can use various http headers to figure
out, "Aha! They're in France."
Maybe we know their user ID from the cookies,
etc.
So we know they prefer using the Swiss French
So we save one round trip there.
And second to that, we also kick off downloading
the initial data in parallel.
So, instead of waiting for everything to start
up, we start downloading. While we're fetching
the JavaScript, we start fetching the initial
data. Note that we didn't bundle the JavaScript
into that very first download.
And the reason we don't want to do that is
because your application will typically change
on a weekly basis, whereas that initial HTML
page will probably change every time you request.
And so, the JavaScript caches a lot better
this way.
And, in this particular example, you see the
initial data actually returns to the browser
before the JavaScript is up and running, which
is great.
It means the second the JavaScript is ready,
we can show a completely loaded application.
So that's using two roundtrips.
And note that we don't want to have to wait
for the communication channel, the RPC channel,
to be up and running.
So we send down the data to the browser in
a lightweight format, perhaps Json.
So that's how we can really speed things up
in your start-up sequence.
>>Joel Webber: So, I'm going to tell you a
little bit about code splitting.
Now, Adam just told you how you can reduce
the number of http requests intrinsic to your
start-up process.
That's certainly going to make a good bit
of difference.
But then, we have another problem. We have
applications.
People tend to like to add more features to
applications, and applications that have more
features tend to get bigger.
As you may know, GWT is a monolithic compiler,
tends to compile all of your app as one big
ball of JavaScript that you then have to download
to the client.
Well, if that thing is growing without bound,
you're eventually going to hit a brick wall.
It's going to get really, really slow on start-up.
So, with the Wave team's input and a strong
desire, we came up with --
>>Adam Schuck: -- very strong.
[laughing]
>>Joel Webber: -- very strong desire. We came
up with what we called code splitting.
This is a compiler.
It is semi-automated, but it is driven by
the compiler. A way of splitting your application
into multiple chunks automatically.
So you have to define as "split points." These
are the places where the compiler is allowed
to split them up.
So, split up fragments so that the user can
take a small hitch during that time.
But then, from there on out, it optimizes
everything automatically.
Your goal is to have one fragment that contains
no more than is strictly needed for your initial
view – whatever, whatever's visible in your
initial page, or set-up of your application.
And to show a quick demo of that, we're going
to go to the --
>>Adam Schuck: --showcase.
>>Joel Webber: -- simple GWT showcase example.
And this is a bit of a contrived example,
because the showcase is naturally divided
into a million little pages. Well, 30 or 40,
let's say.
And what Adam's showing here is the network
graph from Chrome where initially we see this
Indi 5 blob here is the initial page, which
contains really common code and enough code
to get the first page displayed. In this case,
that one checkbox sample.
From there on out, it will fetch subsequent
fragments.
And this app has been really aggressively
split up more to demonstrate the point.
You wouldn't probably split it up quite this
fine-grained in practice.
But the idea is that, anything that's not
needed immediately gets fetched later.
So, in this case, there are a few things that
get fetched fairly early on.
So, what Adam's going to do is, click another
spot in here that will show us a different
sample that was not downloaded, that was not
part of original code.
And, if you watch the network graph on the
right as he does this, you'll see there is
a --
>>Adam Schuck: -- P-N-G. I haven't actually
clicked basic texture.
So let's click this.
>>Joel Webber: Okay, just down at the bottom,
we fetched two new fragments.
Once again, because this is slightly over
split up.
But again, it's just a demonstration.
This allows you to build an app that is essentially
of arbitrary complexity.
As long as you can wait on the compile times;
yeah, it's been known that it can get a little
slow, but we rather you wait than your users
wait.
So you can build really large apps, really
complex apps, and still keep the start-up
very fast.
>>Adam Schuck: Okay, and from the Wave point
of view, as Joel mentioned, we were adamant
that we didn't want to have to stop adding
new features to Wave--
>>Joel Webber: --and they were adding a lot.
>>Adam Schuck: We were adding a lot of features.
[laughing]
Maybe we should have stopped.
But, we kept adding features, and the code
just kept growing.
And we really felt it's important that users
only see the exact code you need for the exact
features that we're showing upfront.
We heavily optimized our start-up sequence
so that we show a loaded inbox first.
We believe perceived latency is the most important
thing to optimize for.
Users should get the impression the application
is loading fast.
And in our opinion, we decided, we want people
to be able to read their new content as quickly
as possible.
Perhaps we'll change that to optimize for
showing individual waves later.
But, we've currently structured our code to
optimize for a full inbox.
And if you try and do something like this,
you're trying to reduce the amount of code
that needs to be downloaded to start your
application. the first question you're going
to ask is, "What is actually in that initial
download?" And there's a really neat tool
created by the GWT to answer our question,
[chuckle] of course, called "compile reports."
And I've got one lying around right here.
So here's a compile report for Google Wave.
And you'll actually see the initial download
size is quite large.
We actually found this gives better performance
in our particular case.
To Joel's point of download everything you
need to see what you want the user to see
upfront.
And we're talking roughly three megabytes
full-code size, less than a meg initial download.
That's huge, but bear in mind that's pre-compression.
And GWT code does compress very well.
And you can click on this link here, "report,"
and see exactly what is in your initial download.
So I can see here Java.util is the number
one contributor by size as a package, and
it contributes 37k.
I can see there's a search panel.
That's a relief.
We're trying to show the search panel, the
inbox, as quickly as possible.
And we can see, aha! You know, the contacts
panel is not loaded.
That is part of the contacts panel, but it's
just some resources.
It's not the full contacts panel.
So we can see how much these things contribute.
And your next question after, "What is in
the initial download?" will be, "Why is it
in the initial download?" And to give an example,
if I click on "framed panel" here, it shows
me exactly what java classes, are in the initial
download, and how big they are.
And the exact call stack from your on-module
load all the way through to the class.
So this is a really useful tool for identifying
"why", not just "what", is in your initial
download.
Also, to talk a little bit more about Wave
start-up sequence, we mentioned it's important
to fetch your initial data as quickly as possible
in parallel, in fact, to loading your JavaScript.
So we have a very good idea of what information
the user wants in their initial start-up of
the Google Wave Client.
We anticipate this on the servers.
And we start, we use transfer encoding of
chunk on the server, and we start sending
small amounts of information up to the browser
as it is available.
And what we could do there, so we have "contact
starter," "inbox starter," "wave data," we
can send this all up when we get it.
But note that you actually block the client
if it has to evaluate that JavaScript.
So rather, what we found we do, because we're
optimizing for an inbox loading quickly, is
we send that particular piece of data quick,
and then, everything else as we get it.
As mentioned, we code split to optimize for
an initial download that shows an inbox.
And overall, our results in the last six months
that we've been thinking about this problem,
we've made the median two seconds, it used
to be five seconds; and for all of our users
in Africa or Australia, 90th percentile, it
used to be 16 seconds, now, its 7 seconds.
These are ballparks.
And you can see now, we are within that 10
second time limit that I mentioned as being
so important.
And, of course, we're doing more work to make
this faster.
We want to reduce that code size.
>>Joel Webber: So earlier, Adam mentioned
optimization of the start-up process; reducing
http requests by doing script selection on
the server.
This is one thing that was built by another
team within Google that's used by Wave in
a number of products.
And we're going to be open sourcing this as
soon as time permits, so you won't have to
roll your own custom link in order to do this
yourself.
And we'll bring that into GWT proper so you
can all take advantage of it.
So, second point, fetching data.
Again, as I mentioned, the…fetching data…we're
talking about over the Internet.
Internet is slow, or it's always slower than
you want it to be at least.
There's really two things this boils down
to.
There is, fetching data you don't need, that
is, fetching more data than is needed to actually
display what the user is looking for and needs
to see.
And there's fetching it in too many http requests.
The latter is a subtle point that, if you
fetch a small amount of data spread out over
a lot of http requests, then it's still going
to be slow, because the http overhead is eating
you alive.
So, you have to consider both of these things
and have different strategies for dealing
with them.
First one is a little subtle.
It's not as simple to deal with.
If you've ever built client-server applications,
like LAN applications, say back in the early
90s when Google was doing that, you tended
to sort of have a 2-tiered process, right?
You have a database in the back end; you have
a really chatty communication on the front
end.
You munge all the data and display it in the
UI.
That was at least very common.
It's fairly easy to do.
Problem with that is that it's chatty.
You download a lot of data you don't need
typically, and that doesn't work so well for
the Internet.
So, what we found really works well as a strategy
is to design your RPC system, be it RPC Json,
fetch or whatever, to support the UI directly.
Make sure the UI can ask questions of the
server in terms that will give it precisely
what it needs and no more.
Don't fetch anything you don't need.
Be careful of types. If you're used to GWT
RPC system, it's really nice, because it's
automated. It will walk your reference graph
and figure out how to download all the objects
referenced by another object and so forth
transitively, but that can also lead to situations
where you download stuff you didn't realize
because it's being so helpful that it sent
a bunch of stuff so that it satisfies all
the references.
You have to be careful with that.
So watch your payload size and watch which
object you're sending out over the wires.
Sometimes it makes sense to use specialized
DTOs to the client, that may not be the same
ones you use in the back end, so that you
don't trigger this problem.
The other issue, as I mentioned before, is
the http requests.
So, this is a super-simplified version or
imaginative version of the Wave Client server
protocol.
It doesn't actually work this way for reasons
that will become clear in a moment.
Now, you might say, "Well, I'll just have
each piece of my UI talk to an RPC interface,
get data that it needs from the back end."
This is written in terms of the GWT RPC semantics
roughly, but the same thing applies no matter
what you're using: Json, XML, or what have
you.
The problem with this is that, very often,
a single user interaction leads to a bunch
of requests.
And the reason this happens is that you say,
imagine I'm in wave, I click on a wave.
I've got to fetch the header, to display that.
I've got to fetch the wave itself, so I can
display that.
But also, because I want to keep the rest
of the UI up to date, I use this opportunity
also go fetch the status of my contacts.
I have to fetch the inbox, an updated version
of the inbox perhaps, that's deltas, or what
have you.
You get the idea.
I'm fetching a bunch of stuff from one user
interaction. Well, this would translate into
four http requests, and they can get serialized
because mini-browsers have a 2-connection
limit.
Even the modern browsers will have a 2-connection
limit on the slow connection so they don't
saturate the link.
So that ends up being really, really bad in
practice when your UI has, it really has two
problems, one, it's slow.
Two, it feels really slow, because these things
come in at different rates.
So, this pops in, that pops in, that pops
in, that pops in.
The whole UI kind of jiggles and feels awkward
and sluggish.
The easy way to fix this, well, relatively
easy, is to actually restructure your RPC
interface such that you break it into "request
object" and "response objects."
You build a single interface, at least for
the purpose of most of the UI, that allows
you to batch all of those requests.
So, all the different parts of the UI that
need information will populate an array of
request objects, array of list request objects,
go to the server, server processes all those,
sends back the response objects, and the piece
of code doing the transfer goes off and farms
those responses off of the appropriate parts
of the UI.
And a really simple way of doing this is simply
to use a deferred command.
If you're more familiar with JavaScript, it's
equivalent to using "set timeout zero," more
or less.
And that allows you to aggregate your requests
based on a single user interaction.
The idea is that a deferred command will run
after the current event handler is done, which
almost invariably corresponds to a single
user action.
And when that thing fires, you take all the
requests that have been batched up by different
parts of the UI, and it fires them off to
the server to be handled.
That allows the server to optimize things,
so like hot database connections and so forth
can be used for all these different requests
being made.
And it allows the different parts of the UI
to be written independently, because they
all just use this simple add request interface
to get their data.
They don't need to know about each other,
which keeps your code simpler.
And that can lead to, again, a single http
request for user action, which is your goal.
Okay, third part, rendering.
Again, we're talking about a web browser here,
unusual performance characteristic, even the
best of them.
And when your rendering is slow, you really
run into two problems.
One, you run into all the problems that come
with being slow, "You just don't want your
app to be slow.
Your users won't like it."
But also, on the rendering side, on the client
side, you block your UI thread.
And that's particularly bad because, on most
browsers, that means that user can't even
switch tabs off from Windows.
And they can't do anything. They can't click
the back button; they can't close the window
until that action is free.
So if you have something rendering taking
several seconds, which is not unheard of if
you're not careful, then it's a really, really
bad user experience.
And that's what Kelly Norton's talk was referring
to, the sluggishness; really, really important
thing to avoid.
This happens really in two places.
When you're creating widgets and you're getting
data on to the screen.
"Creating widgets" really means creating the
scaffolding, a place where you're going to
put all your data, and then, there's actually
populating the data.
And really, when I say "widgets," I'm specifically
referring to GWT widgets.
The same thing applies for JavaScript widgets
and so forth, but I'll speak in terms of widgets.
And there's two cases where you end up with
widgets that you don't need.
Either you create them too early, that is,
you've created widgets that are not visible
yet, and therefore, they were a waste of time.
You could have amortized that and created
them when they were needed.
And you've created ones you didn't need at
all.
So, things, creating widgets that do simple
things like "layout," I'll go more into detail
on how you can deal with this later, is often
unnecessary.
You can just simply get away with standard
HTML.
It's often easier as well.
And a simple case, so, I mentioned earlier
about where I'm going to go, creating widgets
too early.
So if you imagine a simple case of a tab panel.
Got five tabs.
You've got one thing that's visible, four
things by definition not visible initially,
four things that I probably shouldn't have
created yet.
A really simple pattern for this.
If I just say "lazy initialization," you can
probably guess what I mean and figure out
how to do it.
There is a lazy panel that is a simple way
of doing this that's built-in, but the pattern
is very, very easy to imagine.
Just wait until something is shown, then create
the widget.
And, in fact, there's a large hierarchy of
widgets that can make a huge difference.
So, I also mentioned that you should avoid
creating widgets that you simply don't need.
And the reason widgets are slow, I say they're
slow. They're slow relative to their HTML
counterparts, is because they do extra work.
They do extra work to deal with event handling,
then you've got memory leaks, so forth and
so on.
And if you don't need it, then there's no
reason to run that code.
I often like to say, "The fastest code is
the code you never run."
Only widgets that actually need to handle
events really even need to exist.
And in some cases, even those don't need to
exist.
So, if you can aggregate event handling at
a higher level, at an outer widget that contains
some simpler constructs inside. We use this
in things like "tree" and some of the table
widgets.
Then, you can optimize the creation of these
things a lot further.
And there is an easy way now to create HTML
elements for widgets where you may have used
widgets before in UiBinder.
I'll cover that very briefly and go into more
detail later.
So, use your I binder to replace widgets with
HTML, again, often the easier thing to do.
In GWT 2.1, we have added a series, or are
in the process of adding a series, of cell-based
lists trees and tables.
We call these "data presentation widgets."
You may have seen Bruce Johnson demonstrate
these this morning.
These are extremely fast waves during your
large collections of data.
Because, oftentimes, if you're talking about
a "table" or "tree" or something like that,
all the individual items are actually very
simple.
There's no reason to use heavyweight widgets
for all of those.
I won't go into great detail on this right
now, but tomorrow morning, Ray Ryan and myself
are giving a talk describing these in much
more detail on how you can use them in your
apps to speed them up drastically.
So UiBinder, for those not familiar, this
is a simple XML structure that we introduced
in 2.0 that allows you to use XML to describe
what would normally have been a lot of Java
boilerplate.
But a side effect of this is, it also makes
it really easy to mix widgets with HTML elements,
so you just create HTML if that's what you
want.
It also makes it easier to mix CSS with your
widgets, associate them directly, and also
avoid slow CSS patterns.
So, things like descendant selectors, in this
case here, you see a div at the link of a
descendant selector.
That can be an extremely slow pattern to match.
This structure, which I'll show in a moment,
really makes it easy to avoid these kinds
of cases, which are very common in traditional
CSS.
>>Adam Schuck: And aside from the performance
benefits of using UiBinder, there's also a
really nice code cleanliness quality to using
UiBinder.
The Google Wave team, we proudly boasted a
4,000-line CSS file which nobody, one person
in the team, knew how it worked and everyone
else feared deeply.
And I think we managed to very successfully
carve that up into lots of 50-line CSS files
scattered throughout our code base, living
in the same package as the code that uses
them.
This also has the added performance benefit
of; they get pulled down with code-splitting
at the exact point in time that they're used.
So code cleanliness and performance working
together.
It's really great.
They're not competing goals in this particular
example.
What you're looking at here is an actual UiBinder
template from Google Waves code base.
This is a contact.
So the little avatar image with the person
speaking.
And using UiBinder, we can pull all this CSS
in place and connect this up to our Java.
And Joel's going to tell us how.
>>Joel Webber: So two things to note here.
There won't be a pop quiz; you don't have
to memorize this.
What I've highlighted first here is, you notice
these UI field attributes.
What these do is describe how you're actually
going to bind the individual elements created
for you into your code.
Because you could've simply write something
like this with an interHTML call, put it in
text in your Java code, but it's really hard
to actually get the elements back out again
once they've been created.
UiBinder automates this process.
And while there are no leaf widgets in this
case, there could be widgets mixed into this.
So you might have, if you had a G: button
element as a leaf in here, that would work
as well.
So, it'll again, allows you to mix them freely.
This allows you to, in this case here, you'll
notice because they're all HTML elements,
it allows you to quickly get references to
the pieces you need so that you can populate
them with data.
But there are no widgets in here, because
the only events that are handled are mouse
and click events at the top level.
So that's just handled in the outermost widget:
keeps it simple, keeps it fast.
The other thing I mentioned earlier is CSS.
So this uses standard class attributes for
binding CSS to elements.
Same thing goes if you're binding it to widgets
and I've got this G-style element right here.
It's part of the same file even though they're
separate boxes.
These are individual rules. They're all simple
rules, a single class selector, that are extremely
fast to match.
So you're not angering the CSS performance
gods by making complex selectors.
And UiBinder takes care of the process of
obfuscating and name spacing these things
so they don't conflict with one another.
So, you can have something called "dot name"
and not worry about somebody in some other
team in another continent who after creating
another "dot name" which conflicts and causes
your UI to do strange things.
>>Adam Schuck: So UiBinder, very good for
both performance and cleanliness of code.
So there's really no excuse not to use them.
>>Joel Webber: Per this virtue is the pit
of success.
Where doing the easy thing is the fast thing
or the correct thing.
>>Adam Schuck: All right. Shall we demo?
>>Joel Webber: We shall.
>>Adam Schuck: Okay.
>>Joel Webber: Okay. So, you may have seen
this enormously fascinating application at
the keynote this morning.
What's really fascinating about this app is
not that it's about expense reports, sort
of a dry subject.
What's fascinating about it is that it's fast,
assuming that my application hasn't cooled
down in the meantime.
Here we go. It's normally fast.
That's app engine. That's not the GWT side.
I'm not speaking about app engine.
It is…importantly, there are practically
no widgets in this demo.
There are, I think the last count, there are
approximately 25 total widgets for the core
string superstructure for a couple of the
individual elements.
But the rest of it is all rendered using the
new list tables, trees, data presentation
widgets we're adding in 2.1.
And what this allows you to do importantly
is things like this, that we probably would
not have even bothered to try before because
it would be too slow using a complex widget
structure.
So as I type here, you'll notice that it is
highlighting as I type.
That seems like a reasonable thing to desire.
I'm sure UI guys would love it, but it would
have been a pain before.
This now is extremely fast to render.
And there's no reason that you should worry
about any complexity in your UI using these.
It should always be reasonably performing,
in this case extremely fast.
This also brings us to another question that
has come up a lot is …should I? Let's say,
I'm writing an app.
I'm finding that it's getting kind of slow.
I'm using a lot of widgets, getting slow.
And I'm starting to wonder if maybe I should
be rendering my HTML on the server.
You know, that seems like a really complex
thing to do, but it's a question that often
comes up.
And it may have been true at one point.
Now, what we've found is that, when we moved,
when we built these widgets, they're carefully
optimized to use in their HTML web wherever
possible, optimized string manipulations and
so forth.
In a way that you don't have to be exposed.
So you don't have to worry about it.
And we found, in the vast majority of cases,
it is at least as fast as rendering static
HTML from the server without the added network
overhead.
And in many cases, it actually outruns downloading
HTML from the server.
The only cases where we found where it really,
where it can still come out behind, is either
when you're talking about progressively rendering
static HTML; but that only applies to your
first page.
So if you have a page that has extremely high-latency
requirements, you can render it from the server,
sort of decorate the HTML and so forth.
But that really only helps you on the first
page.
After that, you're still working on the Client.
And the other case is when you have extremely
complex calculations going on to produce the
actual HTML that you're rendering.
That really only comes up in rare cases.
I think Wave has a few of them when it comes
to Wave rendering.
And I've seen a couple of other apps.
But usually, you should almost never start
there.
You should almost always begrudgingly move
any kind of rendering to the server.
This pretty much takes care of the vast majority
of those cases as far as we can tell, so far.
>>Adam Schuck: And the Wave team is looking
into using a server side rendering approach.
We definitely think, as mentioned, the start-up
sequence; you've got to do two JavaScript
roundtrips to get the data.
If you can really just send down HTML and
go "set HTML" on the page.
And then, when JavaScript is fired up, swap
in some content.
We do believe that we can get some performance
gains.
>>Joel Webber: But again, do that begrudgingly.
It's a lot of work.
>>Adam Schuck: We're doing it begrudgingly.
[laughing]
It's a lot of work.
>>Joel Webber: One other thing to set stage
for is, what I usually refer to as "on-demand
rendering" or "on-the-draw widgets" if you
will.
Often referred to as "infinite scrolling."
The idea is to render only what's literally
on the screen.
So if you have a large scrollable area, you
fake out the scrollable part, and then, you
render elements or widgets as they are, as
they come into view.
And we haven't actually implemented this yet
except in some internal demos; but this sets
the stage for doing that quickly and efficiently.
So, we think this will make a huge difference
for really, really large collections.
And Wave has implemented it for both the inbox
or search view, so, all the items that you
see in that scrolling view.
And also, for Waves themselves.
So waves that are 3 or 400 blips long.
If you rendered all of those upfront, it would
be fairly slow, as you've probably seen in
the past.
But now, it's much, much faster as a result
of rendering only the visible elements.
>>Adam Schuck: That's right. So we're seeing,
we calculate roughly a 4x improvement.
And statistically, that's looking at the averages.
So we've got very different sizes of waves.
But, now we really do, it's much faster if
you want to jump to the end of a wave as I
showed you previously at the start of this
talk, because we don't worry about rendering
all the content in a linear order.
Okay. If I may?
>>Joel Webber: You may.
>>Adam Schuck: So, we're now up to the fourth
of the four areas where we think you can improve
your application's performance.
So we've talked about start-up.
We've talked about fetching the data, we've
talked about rendering.
Now to talk about another one of these sub-tenth
of a second hot spots: user interactions.
When a user is interacting directly with your
application, clicking buttons, typing, we're
really shooting at that tenth of a second
barrier.
And there's a great talk, in fact, if you
attended the Speed Tracer talk this morning,
you learned it's a really great deep dive
into this topic.
We're going to stay somewhat high-level.
And these interactions, there's a few places
where time can build up.
Slow event handlers, so, we block the UI thread.
So if we do too much processing while we're
handling the UI, it could potentially take
more than a tenth of a second.
Click events, if I click, I want to see a
change immediately.
That's what I'm used to.
Mouse events, if I'm dragging, hovering, you
don't want that "sluggishness" as we're using
the word.
Key events: typing, navigation, and also window
resizes, all these things you should make
them fast.
One general tip is, if there is a browser
feature, rather than you having to write code,
use it.
Turns out, writing less code also means it's
going to be faster.
So we're moving towards using CSS animations,
for example, rather than JavaScript.
And a lot of the new GWT widgets are doing
exactly that, which is, relying on clever
CSS positioning rules to improve the performance.
[pause]
We're talking about perceived latency.
So you want to keep the application feeling
responsive at all points in time.
And remember, even though you're writing your
code in Java using GWT, you are actually in
fact in a single-threaded environment.
What this means is that, if you want an event
to be processed, I click a button.
If you're still doing some JavaScript processing,
we have to wait for this processing to be
complete.
So it's best to parcel your JavaScript into
lots of small fragments so that we can keep
the application responsive at all points in
time.
And if you look at this diagram I have here.
And if you don't mind zooming in on a few
things.
This is from our experiments we found that
the on-mouse-down event tends to trigger before
the on-mouse-up event by half a second.
So there's a really easy optimization to make
there.
Do processing on on-mouse-down rather than
on-mouse-up and you'll give people the impression
everything's half a second faster just by
switching the event you use.
Okay?
And another important trick which we use throughout
the wave user interface is what we call "optimistic
UI," optimistic user interface, where we assume
everything is going to work.
If I type, we assume it will correctly get
persisted to the server; it worked.
Rather than roundtrip, update, okay, we managed
to persist it.
Now, show it to the user.
It's a really good tip for all of you to use
in your applications.
Give the user the impression that everything
worked and give them buttons like "undo" or
"error notifications" after the fact.
That way, you're optimizing for the case where
everything works.
If you're writing a good application, everything
will work fast.
And one way to do this is to use GWT's deferred
command.
That way, if I click a button, we do the thing
that it associates with.
So, if I'm typing in Wave, show the text.
And in a deferred command, because we need
the browser to update; we need to yield to
the browser to refresh.
Now, we send off requests and use a batching
approach as Joel mentioned.
So, really keep the application feeling as
responsive as possible by deferring any kind
of busy work, anything that will take longer
than a tenth of a second.
>>Joel Webber: The other thing that Adam mentioned
a moment ago was leaning on the browser, leaning
on native code.
If you don't have to write it, that's also
good.
And leaning on native code is always faster.
So resizing, again, we resize a panel within
something like Wave, or resize the window
itself.
If that's sluggish, the app feels awkward
and uncomfortable.
It just doesn't feel good.
And in GWT 2.0, we introduced these layout
panels that actually lean on these process
very heavily and very carefully so that you
can get predictable layout that is also very,
very fast.
We won't go in deep dive on that right now,
but again, tomorrow morning's talk, we'll
go into that in quite some detail.
You should definitely be using these.
It helps you move your standards mode and
it helps you keep things fast.
And it makes your life a lot easier.
>>Adam Schuck: Okay, so we've told you four
places and some tips on how to make your application
much faster.
Now, here's a hypothetical.
You spend a few months; you use Speed Tracer
and some great tools; you figure out exactly
why your application is slow; you make it
faster.
And somehow, another developer on your team
touches one line of code, and the initial
download doubles in size or clicks are being
handled irresponsibly.
This is not that hypothetical.
This happened very much on the Google Wave
team.
And we learned our lesson hopefully so none
of you have to make the exact same mistake
as us.
Things will get slower unless you are paying
attention to them.
So it's very important that you to do latency-regression
testing.
Have, most of you would have TVs in your office
showing the state of your continuous build;
it's green or it's red.
It's just as important to track how fast your
application is.
So, the two main areas you want to track,
plot your download size.
As we mentioned, if you have a slow Internet
connection, the size actually does make a
big difference.
Plot your initial size, so we care about start-up
time.
But also your total to see if there's any
ridiculous jumps in how much code is being
added, any inefficient JavaScript.
And then, the other aspect is measure.
Actually measure the performance in milliseconds,
in seconds, of your application.
For Wave, we care about the Client loading
fast, waves opening fast, search performing
quickly. There's a lot of other things, but
really, it's best to focus on a small number
of key metrics for your application.
And measure them both in production conditions,
what your user's experience.
It's important to note, you don't want your
whole team saying, "Yeah, it's fast."
And all your users saying, "Wow, it's slow
today."
So it's really important you know what your
users are feeling; and also, lab conditions.
And I'll explain why in a second.
Plotting your download size, very important.
As mentioned earlier, Wave team, we love adding
new features.
So up, up, up, up, up, up, when our initial
download.
Then we politely ask the GWT team to create
code-splitting for us.
And much later, you see a sharp drop.
And actually later on, we found out it's not
optimal to just make it as small as possible,
because we want the inbox to be optimized.
The other interesting thing in this chart,
the other reason you want to track it, it's
not just to celebrate whenever it goes down,
but whenever you spot a regression.
So if Joel just zooms in on this little hill
we have here.
Somebody in our team accidentally checked
in an Adobe Photoshop PNG with all the layers.
Rather than a nice, compressed, crushed PNG
file.
We noticed this on the chart. Everyone went,
"Why did it go up?"
"Aha! We know now." We made it go down.
So it's great to track this, because you find
when you make mistakes, and we're all human
here.
It's much better to set up the system; rather
than assume you're not going to make mistakes
and trust each other, dare I say it.
Timing is very important.
So, it's important to track what your users
feel.
And you can see, it's a noisy data.
But we're looking at here, creation of a wave
from the search panel.
And when we rolled out this on-demand rendering,
we saw a sharp drop, which is great.
It's really useful to see this information,
because every week you get to see a jump in
your chart, and you go, "Aha! We're faster."
Everyone rejoices, pop open a few beers, and
everyone's happy.
Then, the next question comes, "Why is it
faster?" And everyone puts up their hand and
says, "It's because of what I did."
Why does this happen?
Because we only push a new version of our
application every week, so, we don't actually
know why it got faster, why it got slower.
And it's very important to know what your
users are experiencing, but the next question
can't be answered by this data.
This is why we do lab timings.
So, we actually track, we run every hour in
a controlled environment.
We open waves 20 times in an average data
and get medians.
And what you're looking at here is the client
load inquirim.
This is in a controlled environment.
So, pretty close to "runs every time somebody
commits code," which is important.
And we can see here…the chart went up.
Somebody made our client load ten percent
slower.
In the old days, we'd find this out one week
later when we got those big charts.
Now, we know exactly what happened.
Somebody does a binary search, runs a test
in the lab.
"Aha!" And then, a little bit later, we fix
the regression; really important to track
this.
This is how you keep your application fast
once you've made it fast.
And the other point of interest in the top
right chart is, this is Wave-opening Chrome.
So it's good news when it goes up, because
we fix it.
And it's good news when it goes down, because
we made something faster.
And now, when we're celebrating on a Friday
afternoon that we made everything faster and
someone looks around the room, only one person
gets to put their hand up.
So we now know who's going to fix bugs and
we know who gets the credit.
And turns out, motivating people in your team,
if you just measure something, it's going
to get faster.
That's just something we've noticed on the
Wave team.
Some other tools that are really interesting.
Speed Tracer, if you went to the talk this
morning, you'll have seen.
It's a really fantastic profiler.
Look into it.
If you missed the talk, watch it on YouTube.
Great for deep diving on the rendering and
user-interaction type behavior.
So, we have user events.
And I believe all of the links for everything
I've talked about and Joel has talked about
today will be in the Wave.
So you don't need to furiously write down
URLs if you are.
We also have GWT Inspector widget.
As Joel mentioned, widgets are bad in general.
>>Joel Webber: -- in large quantities.
>>Adam Schuck: In large quantities, widgets
are bad.
So this is a useful little bookmarklet to
tell you how many widgets you have in your
application.
If you feel like a laugh, point this at Google
Wave.
It's actually orders of magnitude larger than
it should be.
We know we have room for improvement.
And Google Page Speed: a great Firefox plug
in helps you improve your start-up performance.
It tells you things like caching, G zipping,
headers, sending cookies.
This is a nice little useful tool to improve
your page speed. And we have time.
>>Joel Webber: We have time.
>>Adam Schuck: Great.
So, I'll give you a quick sample of what we
actually measure if I can find it.
I believe it's this one. Here we go.
So. I mentioned we do lab timings.
We like to measure how quickly waves open.
And we have a special mode of our client which
we run using Selenium.
The automated script clicks speed tests and
runs all these various tests.
And we're going to start opening a large wave,
which, let's see, it has 620 odd participants.
Which is more than we recommend putting on
your waves -- not just for performance reasons,
but if you actually want to get any work done,
that's a lot of people.
And it's got 175 messages in it.
And we run this test every hour.
We get 20 samples.
We extract the data from this.
This is what it looks like for Wave to run
lab timings.
And I'll stop there. Great. [pause]
>>Joel Webber: Couple of odds and ends to
wrap up.
I mentioned before that we work really hard
to do things within GWT, so that you don't
have to do anything.
Usually, those take the form of compiler optimizations
or library optimizations.
In the case of the compiler optimization,
we try to make those default, wherever humanly
possible, so you don't have a rat's nest of
GCT-style command line options.
More recently, we've started discovering some
that have this property that they are incorrect,
but in a way you probably don't care about,
violate Java semantics in minor ways, but
they invariably make your apps smaller and/or
faster.
Those we've had to deal with wrong with tax
options so we don't inadvertently break your
code, which I think you would probably not
prefer.
And as we discover more, we'll keep adding
those.
And as we discover more, we will obviously
document those so that you can take advantage
of them.
And if you were in Ray's talk earlier, I believe
it was just last hour, he goes into some detail
on that.
And if not, I would definitely recommend checking
it out on YouTube.
There's some really interesting stuff going
on in the compiler.
So again, to recap, four things you need to
think about: your app needs to start fast,
you need to get data fast, you need to get
it on the screen fast, and you need to keep
fine-grained user interactions fast…snappy.
>>Adam Schuck: And now that you've made it
fast, keep it fast; measure it, really track
it, and celebrate when your charts go up as
well as when they go down.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>>Adam Schuck: Okay. We're now going to take
some questions both from the microphones if
you're in this room, and we're also going
to use the Wave, which hopefully has some
questions lined up for us.
[pause] Any questions? Nope. All right.
Then we're going to go for the microphone.
>>Joel Webber: We apologize. Dory, the moderator,
did a bit of a face-plant there.
So, but feel free to ask with the mic. And
do go to the mics please.
It's much easier for the recording.
Male #1: Concerning using the CSS files in
Client Bundle?
>>Joel Webber: Mhmm…
>>Male #1: My observation, I've played around
with it some.
It seems like it makes using existing tools
like Firebug or other tools where you can
edit your CSS on the fly a little more difficult.
What's your experience with that?
And how have you gotten around that?
We solve problems like with Firebugs.
If we have CSS problems, we'll play with it,
and I find it a little harder to do that with
it.
>>Joel Webber: Mhhmm--
>>Adam Schuck:--Mhhmm... So from the Wave
perspective?
>>Male #1: Yeah.
>>Adam Schuck: Ok, that's actually an interesting
question.
So, of course, there are a few flags you can
parse into GWT that allow you to leave the
CSS unobfuscated. So there's that.
And that does allow you to play with it in
hosted mode in the time it takes to refresh.
But we have found also in practice that using
it, GWT, in conjunction with Firebug, with
developer tools, very helpful.
It's much quicker to iterate directly on the
HTML.
So that's been our experience.
But the GWT team is working very hard to try
and improve the cycle between actually changing
the source code.
>>Joel Webber: Right, yes. We recognize the
dev mode, hosted mode, AP call, is definitely
slower than it should be and we're definitely
working very hard on that.
But also as Adam said, don't forget to, I
don't recall off the top of my head.
Do look at the docs.
But if you pass in the unobfuscated flag.
I believe it's either a flag or a module you
need to include.
That will turn off obfuscation of the CSS
names, which makes it a lot easier to track
the back and forth between, let's say firebug
editing and the original source.
Not as easy as we'd like it to be and we're
looking into ways to make that better, but
we recognize your pain there. Certainly.
>>Male #2: Yes, I am creating a software application
data -- was going to pull about 5,000 names
from the database.
And so that, you know, like in your example
you just type it in, it pulls the names up.
I know you guys say "Stay away from widget
as much as possible," and I've been trying
to do that.
>>Joel Webber: --Right.
>>Male #2: But what I've been using Json to
pull, to do a serial from the server.
And it's been, the performance has been okay.
I haven't used the Speed Tracer to check it
yet, but I will.
>>Joel Webber: --Right.
>>Male #2: But I wanted to make sure that,
is that the best recommended option where
you're pulling such a large amount of names?
And also, if it isn't, what do you recommend
using to pull like a large database down and
where they'll appear as soon as you type them
in?
>>Joel Webber: So, two things I'd say.
One, most of the serialization formats with
the possible exception of XML, but don't quote
me on that, I'm not positive, are roughly
equivalent in performance, at least in the
same order of magnitude.
So using Json over GWT RPC over XML over protocol
buffer, swift, whatever; they're going to
put you in relatively similar place in terms
of the amount of data.
The piece of, the place where you really have
leverage is in how much data you actually
send at a time.
The problem with all these formats is, you
can't stream them.
You can't say, "Parse the first 37 of these"
unless you actually break it up.
And the only place where you can realistically
do that is on the server, because something
like Json isn't like parsed JavaScript, right?
So you can't parse partway through, or at
least not the way browser is built.
So I would say basically, one, split it up.
So you're not requesting really large chunks.
And also, really large chunks take a long
time to process in addition to being, taking
longer to download.
Split it up, and if you are trying to do something
like type-ahead search, in that sample right
there, that was all client side.
Now, that particular sample also does server
side search, but only when you actually hit
the enter key.
Typically, on the amount of data that you
can actually display on the screen there,
you'd have to work pretty hard to make it
slow to implement something like that type-ahead
search.
As long as your data is indexed or ordered
in the right way.
So, as long as you just limit it to the amount
of data that you can actually get on the screen,
the actual work that you're doing.
You'll typically stay within pretty reasonable
limits. It's only when you get into processing
thousands and thousands of things that you
really get into problems.
And that's the case you want to avoid.
>>Male #2: Okay, yah.
>>Joel Webber: I hope that makes sense.
>>Male #2: Thank you.
>>Adam Schuck: Definitely optimizing to avoid
the network request if you can.
>>Joel Webber: Right here…
>>Male #3 I have a question about, you show
the example where the search filter. You type
a couple of characters in and it would highlight
the right records.
I understand how, if you have a lot of widgets,
it would take a long time to load.
>>Joel Webber: Mhhmm-
>>Male #3: How does it become slow if you
have a lot of widgets by doing that kind of
filtering or typing it in, "highlights," and
then, hitting "enter", and then you end up
with only those records.
How is having a lot of widgets? I feel like
it's intuitively understandable, but maybe
a little more detail.
Why is it slow in that way if you have a lot
of widgets?
>>Joel Webber: Well, there's really two ways
that can get slow.
One is the main thing is the things you would
expect to be fast in a browser, things like,
I don't know, "set text" often aren't when
they're called in large numbers.
So, couple of cases, like if you saw Kelly's
talk earlier this morning about…I think
there was a case where he managed to create
a table that triggered layout thousands of
times.
Things just get slow for freakish and bizarre
reasons.
And what these new widgets that we've built
allow you to do is to, they are designed in
such a way they give us the opportunity to
do the things that we actually know to be
fast.
In this case, it involves aggregating all
those changes into a single interHTML call.
If that is the fastest thing to do.
And we're working on optimizing for all the
various cases that come up.
You know, if I change 3 rows as opposed to
27 of them.
You know, there might be a crossover.
It might be faster to actually go set the
individual text, for example.
But it gives us the leverage to do it in the
right place in the right time in a way that
won't anger the layout gods, for example.
>>Male #3: By keeping it HTML-centered?
>>Joel Webber: Right. By using interHTML where
that actually, where we determined that that's
the fastest thing.
That's typically the reason, especially on
older browsers where they typically optimize
for static HTML rendering.
>>Male #4: You mentioned "infinite scroll"
and the idea of having, I guess, what load
is just what you see it.
Is that something that Google Web Toolkit
does for us or is that still on us to set
that up?
>>Joel Webber: It will as soon as I whip my
hacked-up demos into shape. [laugh]
It's certainly implementable right now.
It's just a little bit like brain surgery.
But, the point, one of the major points, of
building these widgets, is that it allows
us to do that in a really optimal way.
So this is sort of the first step.
I wanted to make sure we got these things
done before we try to tackle that problem.
Because using …tackling that problem on
top of large numbers of widgets just wouldn't
be as effective.
So, look for some demos once the dust settles
after IO and after we get 2.1 out the door
that will start to address this problem.
We're going to try and if you may have noticed,
if you're following our trunk, we've added
this Bike Shed Directory where we can put
totally unfinished, half-baked code and samples
and things like that.
We'll definitely be doing that work in the
open in there.
>>Male #4: Thank you.
>>Adam Schuck: I think we might just have
time for our last two questions.
>>Male #5: Okay. Yeah, towards the beginning
of the call, you mentioned that it's possible
to look at the header information on the server
side and then send back just the skip that's
necessary.
I was also looking for something like that
for HTML 5 application caches where you need
to know exactly the file name.
So my question is, is there any utility or
library or something that lets you map the
user agent name to the appropriate script
name?
>>Joel Webber: Right.
>>Adam Schuck: So we're not doing this yet
for Wave, but there are other applications
within Google that are doing exactly what
you said, selecting the correct version.
I believe that is done in a different way
on the client side, but I'm not actually sure.
I have to get back to you on that one.
But definitely, it is on the roadmap for GWT
to get this service side selection mechanism.
And, of course, an associated app cache mechanism
out into the open source so that everyone
can use it.
>>Joel Webber: Right.
>>Adam Schuck: Because this is not just a
benefit to Google; it's a benefit to anyone
using GWT.
And there's no point in me telling you about
it if you can't use it.
>>Joel Webber: Right. Basically, as soon as
we get the server side selection script ready
for use, anything else that involves affecting
user agent on the server would naturally flow
from there.
So that's sort of the first step.
>>Male #6: I may misunderstood, but I saw
an example in the beginning so you'd request
data before anything is loaded in the browser?
So how does it know that it needs data?
>>Joel Webber: I'm sorry, could you repeat
the question?
>>Male #6: In the beginning you saw that well,
used to be four calls now there are two calls
and it looks like data was requested with
the first page
>>Adam Schuck: Mhmm…
>>Male #6: and then returned asynchronously.
So, how did it know that it needed that data?
>>Adam Schuck: How did we know the user had--?
>>Male #6: --Yeah, because the user is not
smoldered so?
>>Adam Schuck: Okay.
So in the Wave example, we are assuming the
user is already authenticated.
So we know exactly which user it is and we
know that we're going to download the inbox.
Is that the question you're asking?
>>Joel Webber: Using cookies, in other words.
>>Male #6: So, how can it? So, before anything
is loaded in the browser, you can't just request
data, is it?
>>Adam Schuck: So it's the very first request
for the HTML page.
>>Joel Webber: Right. Specifically what they're
doing, if I understand you correctly, is that,
because the request comes with a cookie for
the outer HTML page, it starts sending back
the, it starts fetching from the back end
and then sending back the initial data as
part of the actual outer HTML page.
So, while that page is still streaming down,
because of the way that the start-up semantics
of HTML and JavaScript, you can start running
scripts even though the page isn't fully downloaded
and takes advantage of that.
>>Male #6: Mhmm.
>>Joel Webber: So the page download actually
takes a long time as its streaming back results.
But, the script requests and other kinds of
start-up code can be running while that data
is streaming.
>>Adam Schuck: --That's right.
>>Joel Webber: --That also allows you to wash
out the cost of construction of UI and everything
like that as well.
Like, all of that can take place during that
streaming.
>>Adam Schuck: I'd highly recommend actually
pulling up Firebug or Chrome developer tools
and looking how Wave starts up and just see
how we use the initial HTML page, reuse it
for the data as well as to download the JavaScript.
Okay, we're out of time.
>>Joel Webber: Thanks everybody.
>>Adam Schuck: Thank you very much.
[applause]